Doctor Strange might be able to enter the
Mirror Dimension, Dark Dimension, and Astral
Plane, but he also successfully transcended
to a new level of existence that is just as
impressive — the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
If you're not a sorcerer's apprentice yourself,
though, you might have missed some of the
finer details of the film's finale.
But don't worry, we've got you covered.
Here's the ending of Doctor Strange explained.
The secret of the eye
Don't tell Thanos, but the Eye of Agamotto
is actually an Infinity Stone — the Time
Stone to be precise.
For those of you keeping score at home, that's
the fifth of the six Infinity Stones to appear
in a Marvel movie so far: the Mind Stone is
in Vision's forehead, the Power Stone is held
by the Nova Corps, the Space Stone is in Asgard's
vault, and the Reality Stone is with the Collector.
And since Thanos needs all six to complete
his Infinity Gauntlet, that means Dr. Strange
is on a collision course with the biggest
baddie in the known universe.
Pretty sweet.
The broken watch
Sorry Doctor Palmer, but after the film's
first 20 minutes, it was safe to say that
Stephen Strange will always be married to
his work, not you.
Nevertheless, he still wears the watch she
gave him in order to remember that great gal
who stuck by his side, even back when he was
acting like a total Sherlock.
"There are other things that can give your
life meaning!"
"Like what like you?"
"And this is the part where you apologize."
But that's not all the watch symbolizes.
The shattered face, broken in his car accident,
is a reminder of how pride goeth before a
fall, while the inscription on the back also
prompts Strange to use the time-reversing
powers of the Eye of Agamotto to defeat Dormammu.
The watch may be broken, but thanks to its
many meanings, the Earth is still ticking.
The Sanctum Sanctorum
Kaecilius and his cronies destroyed the London
Sanctum, ruining a good portion of Kamar-Taj
in the process.
And while the Hong Kong Sanctum was saved
with all that time trickery, it still took
a severe beating courtesy of Dormammu's henchmen.
So at the end of the movie, it appears that
Doctor Strange has decided to abandon the
Ancient One's tradition of living in Tibet
and instead has made New York his full time
headquarters — just like in the comics.
He probably just wanted better broadband.
"Uh what's this, my mantra?"
"The wifi password.
We're not savages."
Succeeding the Sorcerer Supreme
With the Ancient One gone, the world heavyweight
title of Sorcerer Supreme has basically been
passed down to the Doctor's broken hands.
And whether or not it's official, he's definitely
earned it: he stopped Kaecilius, he came to
a stalemate with Dormammu, he fixed the Hong
Kong Sanctum, he was chosen by the Cloak of
Levitation, and he saved the planet.
He still maintains vigilance over Kamar-Taj
and the New York Sanctum.
And according to the mid-credits scene, he's
already fulfilling his duties by safeguarding
Earth from threats like Loki.
Thanks, Doc!
Baron Mordo
So why did Baron Mordo turn his back on Dr.
Strange at the end, and then turn into a straight
up villain in the post-credits scene?
Because it was fated — not by a magic prophecy,
but by the comics.
Just like in the movie, comic book Mordo was
the Ancient One's apprentice.
But he eventually went bad, and became Doctor
Strange's archenemy.
Based on the post-credits scene, it seems
like movie Mordo is going down the same path,
meaning we expect to see a lot more of him
in the sequel — as a bad guy.
"This wasn't cleverness, it was suicide!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel and watch more videos like
the one you just saw.
And don't forget to check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love, too!